Nos habéis mandado más de 20.000
mensajes pidiéndonos que hablemos del
escándalo Odebrecht. Para quien no lo
conozca
hablamos del caso de corrupción más
grandes de la historia de Latinoamérica.
Odebrecht es una constructora
brasileña que se ha gastado más de 800
millones de dólares en sobornar a
políticos de prácticamente todos los
países de esa región.
Y no os creáis que hablamos de política a
pequeño nivel. En el escándalo Odebrecht
están implicados presidentes
peruanos mexicanos brasileños y de
prácticamente cualquier país
latinoamericano.
Hasta ahora hemos evitado tocar este
tema en VisualPolitik porque apenas
quedaban cosas nuevas que pudiéramos
aportar que no hayan repetido ya hasta
la saciedad todos los medios de
comunicación.
Lo cierto es que en España apenas ha
tenido repercusión pública pero en
latinoamérica ha sido el auténtico
bombazo informativo.
Sin embargo todavía queda una pregunta
por responder ¿qué va a pasar en
latinoamérica después de Odebrecht?
¿Cómo están reaccionando los distintos
países en este continente? y lo que es
más importante ¿Supondrá Odebrecht el
fin de la corrupción en Latinoamérica?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta y
vamos a centrar este vídeo en Perú
porque ha sido una de los principales
países afectados por este escándalo.
Pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia.
Nuestra historia comienza en brasil país
conocidos por la samba, los actores que
se hacen pasar por colombianos y el
tráfico de influencias.
Como ya sabéis brasil es un país con
grandes recursos de zumo de dinosaurios.
De hecho,
petrobras que es la petrolera de ese
país es una de las empresas más
grandes de todo Latinoamérica.
Durante los años en los que el precio
del barril de crudo estaba por las nubes
petrobras se dedicó a construir
refinerías gasolineras y todo tipo de
edificios amparados por los gobiernos de
Dilma Rousseff y Lula da Silva, que
querían crear puestos de trabajo a toda
costa. Y os preguntaréis ¿A quién les
encargaban todos estos proyectos de
construcción pagados por supuesto con
dinero público?
Pues efectivamente a un grupo de
empresas con contactos en la élite
política brasileña. Cuando esta trama
de corrupción conocida con el nombre de
escándalo lava jato salió a la luz
pública  entonces la presidenta de
brasil dilma rousseff  tuvo que
dimitir y el expresidente del país lula
da silva tuvo que prestar declaración
en un jurado y lo que es más importante
montones de políticos y de empresarios
fueron a la cárcel entre otros
este señor que veis aquí:  Marcelo
Odebrecht, presidente del grupo
odebrecht es que es la constructora más
grande de todo Latinoamérica.
Odebrecht fue fundada en 1944 por un
inmigrante alemán, Norberto Odebrecht.
Pronto se convirtió en una de las
empresas de ingeniería más innovadoras
del mundo y su modelo de gestión
descentralizado y su cultura del mérito
ha sido alabada por escuelas de negocios
en todo el mundo. Durante años Odebrecht
fue la envidia de todas las demás
constructoras ¿cómo era posible que
ganará todos los concursos de obras
pública? ¿Cuál era su secreto? ¿Cómo
podían ser capaces de expandirse a
otros países con tanta facilidad? - Cuando
uno conoce lo que haces tiene la plena
seguridad de que el trabajo lo hace con
responsabilidad y seguridad sobre todo,
no hay ningún problema". Pues bien tras
la captura de Marcelo Odebrecht todos
descubrimos que ese secreto era tan
simple como el pago de sobornos a los
políticos indicados.
Esta constructora había financiado las
campañas políticas de dilma rousseff y
lula da silva pero no solo eso,
también habían regalado mansiones a
otros políticos como el actual
presidente de brasil Michel Temer y
habían repartido más de 30 millones de
dólares en sobornos y regalos entre
funcionarios de la administración
brasileña y de la empresa Petrobras.
Pero esperad un momento porque ahora llega
lo más importante.
Lo cierto es que para rebajar su condena
Marcelo Odebrecht decidió prestar
declaración a la policía no sólo a la
brasileña sino también al departamento
de justicia del gobierno de
Estados Unidos. Y mis queridos amigos  de VisualPolitik
ahí es cuando descubrimos que la trama
Odebrecht se extendía mucho más allá de
las fronteras de Brasil.
Básicamente el grupo Odebrecht tenía su
propio departamento de sobornos al que
llamaban sector de relaciones estratégicas.
Se ha conocido que los países a los que la
constructora brasileña pagó sobornos
en américa latina fueron: colombia
brasil ecuador república dominicana y
méxico guatemala panamá venezuela y
perú convirtiéndose así en el
personaje central de toda la trama
descubierta por la operación lava jato.
Hablamos de más de 800 millones de
dólares destinados a comprar a
políticos de prácticamente todos los
países de Latinoamérica. Para que os
hagáis una idea 800 millones de dólares
es lo que cuesta producir toda la nueva
trilogía de star wars. Y esto afecta a
todo el mundo tanto políticos de
izquierdas como políticos de derechas:
venezolanos, colombianos, peruanos
brasileños mexicanos. El caso Odebrecht
es una bomba política de tal magnitud
que sería prácticamente imposible
enumerar todas las obras que han
realizados gracias al tráfico de
influencias y os preguntareis ¿Cómo
es posible que sobornarán
tantísimos políticos sin que nadie se
diera cuenta?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Este jesucristo gigante que veis aquí
no está en río de janeiro sino en lima
la capital de perú y fue un regalo de
Odebrecht al por entonces presidente del
país Alan García.
Y lo cierto es que este hombre había
hecho méritos más que suficientes para
conseguir este premio: su país es uno de
los más afectados por esta trama de
corrupción. De hecho, todos los ex
presidentes peruanos desde fujimori
hasta ollanta humala han recibido
presuntamente sobornos por parte de esa
empresa. Pero de todos los casos de
corrupción
el más emblemático es el de la famosa
autopista interoceánica una moderna y
segura carretera une cuzco con puerto
maldonado en poco tiempo ¡5.500
kilómetros de carretera para conectar
perú con Brasil!
Este macroproyecto se construyó entre
el año 2001 y el año 2002 bajo la
presidencia de alejandro Toledo. Odebrecht
ganó el concurso porque había
presentado la oferta más barata
de todas: 800 millones de dólares.
Sin embargo tan pronto como las obras
comenzaron los gastos se multiplicaron.
Al final esta autopista interoceánica
terminó costando tres veces más de lo
que habían presupuestado originalmente
y con fallos de construcción tan graves
como éste.
Por si esto fuera poco las
investigaciones muestran que la
concesión de este proyecto se dio en un
tiempo récord es decir
normalmente cuando un gobierno ya sea
local o nacional quiere hacer una obra
pública
saca un concurso al que se presentan
distintas empresas. Despues, varios
comités de expertos analizan todas las
propuestas y sacan un informe que
tendrá que tener en cuenta el
político de turno a la hora de tomar la
decisión de a quién darle la
concesión de ese proyecto.
Todo ese proceso lógicamente suele
durar varios meses.
Sin embargo en este caso se hizo en una
cuestión de semanas y esto es lo que
explica cosas como ésta: El presidente
Alejandro Toledo habría recibido una
coima de 20 millones de dólares. Según
las últimas investigaciones
este mismo sistema es el que habría
estado utilizando Odebrecht para conseguir
proyectos de obra pública en 12 países
de latinoamérica y por supuesto
montones y alcaldes de ministros y de
presidentes del gobierno se han hecho
millonarios. Sin embargo, las reacciones a
este caso han sido muy distintas en cada
país.
Por ejemplo, en Venezuela Nicolás Maduro
se ha limitado a pedir que se haga
justicia y que se metan en la cárcel a
los implicados pero por lo demás parece
que el tema como que no va con el.
Odebrecht fue destruida totalmente y
tenía  dos grandes proyectos aquí por su
capacidad de ingeniería y de acción y
ya.. bueno quienes quedaron encargados de
Odebrecht en el país están entregando todas
la obras y lo digo, con ingeniería,
con capacidad constructiva y con
inversión venezolana
vamos a terminar todas las obras que
empezó Odebrecht y que abandonó
producto de su propia crisis, todas
las obras las vamos a terminar. En otros
países como panamá distintas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
están recogiendo apoyos para crear una
comisión internacional que investigue
el caso a nivel global en lugar de ir
país por país. Y en otros lugares como
méxico todavía están recogiendo
pruebas y buscando a los políticos
implicados.
El problema que esto no es un caso
aislado.
Antes de este escándalo Odebrecht, la
empresa alemana siemens se había gastado
más de 400 millones de dólares en
sobornar a políticos de méxico
argentina y Venezuela. Y en España no
creáis que nos quedamos atrás. Tenemos
el caso de los eres de Andalucía, la
trama gürtel, el caso palau y otros
tantos que me dejó por el camino.
En resumen que la corrupción es algo
común en los países latinos y aquí
tenemos que incluir a españa y Portugal.
Así que la pregunta que cabe hacerse es
la siguiente:
Los daneses pueden estar orgullosos de
dos cosas: la primera es que son líderes
mundiales en producción de esas
galletas de mantequilla que no saben a
nada pero que hacen las delicias de las
abuelas en todo el mundo.
La segunda es que son el país menos
corrupto del planeta. Tal cual como lo
escucháis.
Según todos los organismos
internacionales
dinamarca es el lugar más limpio de
sobornos y de tráfico de influencias
del mundo.
Y os preguntareis ¿Qué tienen los daneses
que no tengamos los demás?
Por supuesto que hay una parte cultural,
por ejemplo según el eurobarómetro el
67% de los españoles creemos que las
conexiones políticas son
imprescindibles para el éxito en un
negocio.
Eso significa que si un español quiere
ganar dinero con su empresa es muy
probable que lo primero que intente
hacer sea llevarse bien con el gobierno
de turno.
Sin embargo en dinamarca sólo el 15% de
la población opina que las conexiones
políticas son tan importantes para el
éxito de un negocio.
Pero esperad un momento porque ésta no es
la única razón. Por ejemplo ¿qué
pasaría si Odebrecht se presentará a
un concurso para construir una carretera
en Copenhague? Vamos a imaginar que
sobornan al alcalde de esta ciudad para
que les de el proyecto.
Lo cierto es que no le serviría de nada
porque la comisión encargada de juzgar
todas las propuestas está creada no por
políticos sino por una comisión de
expertos,
y por si fuera poco estos expertos son
totalmente desconocidos por las empresas
que se presentan al concurso. Es decir
que esa persona, ese representante
de Odebrecht encargado de sobornar a los
cargos públicos
simplemente no sabría con quien
tendría que contactar. Pero eso no es
todo.
Vamos a imaginar que a pesar de todos
estos impedimentos Odebrecht consigue
descubrir quiénes son los miembros del
jurado y les ponen una mansión a cada
uno de ellos.
Pues resulta que todos los debates que
tengan estos miembros del jurado para
dirimir cuál es el proyecto ganador
tienen que estar gravados y todas las
empresas que se presentan a concurso
pueden exigir a la administración que
les den las grabaciones y toda la
documentación que se ha utilizado en el
proceso. Es más,  existe un tribunal paralelo
llamado autoridad de la competencia a
quienes se le puede denunciar cualquier
irregularidad que exista en un proceso
de concurso público.
Pero esperad, porque aquí no termina la
cosa ¿recordáis que Odebrecht
solía a renegociar los presupuestos
cuando ya estaban a mitad de la obra?
Pues bien, en Dinamarca sólo lo podrían
hacer si se dan unas condiciones muy
concretas: por ejemplo mientras están
construyendo la autopista descubren
un nuevo yacimiento arqueológico
que hace que la obra sea más cara, sí que
podrían sentarse otra vez con la
administración y renegociar el contrato.
Pero por supuesto tendrían que
demostrarlo y pasar por una comisión de
expertos.
Y, ojo, porque en otros países como en
alemanía la cosa es todavía peor. En
este país si Odebrecht quisiera ampliar
el coste de una obra tendría que
pagarlo de su propio bolsillo
Y sí todo esto os parece poco aquí llega
la guinda del pastel: sí a pesar de todos
estos controles o Odebrecht consigue
corromper a los políticos y se pudiera
probar en un juicio, esta empresa
estaría repudiada para siempre por
todas las instancias del gobierno danés.
Es decir, no podrían volver a
presentarse a ningún concurso público
a no ser que demostrasen que han hecho
la llamada autolimpieza y eso implica
pagar multas millonarias, despedir a
todos los trabajadores implicados en los
sobornos y varias auditorías que
dejarían las cuentas de la empresa temblando.
Y por cierto, antes de nada tengo que
darle las gracias a la profesora Teresa
Medina Arnaiz del departamento de
derecho público de la universidad de
burgos en españa por haberme ayudado a
entender todos los pormenores de la ley
danesa.
En resumen, que la corrupción es algo
que se puede evitar.
Ahora bien, hacen falta las leyes
adecuadsa y por eso en VisualPolitik
tenemos que aplaudir la decisión que ha
tomado el gobierno de perú.
Como os decía antes
Perú es uno de los países más
afectados por el escándalo Odebrecht.
Todos sus ex presidentes desde fujimori
hasta ollanta humala han estado
envueltos de una forma u otra en los
sobornos.
E incluso, el ex presidente Alejandro
Toledo está puesto en búsqueda y
captura. Y precisamente por esto cuando
Odebrecht ha tenido que paralizar todas
sus obras y todas sus operaciones debido
al aluvión de acusaciones que les
están llegando,
Perú también ha sido el país más
afectado.
Sin embargo,
el gobierno de perú ha sido capaz de
cobrar la indemnización correspondiente
por el incumplimiento de obligaciones
por parte de la empresa y con ese dinero
que les ha llegado han vuelto a convocar
un nuevo concurso de obras públicas
para terminar de construir el gasoducto.
Pero lo más importante de todo ha sido
este anuncio hecho por el presidente de
Perú Pedro Pablo Kuczynski del nuevo
decreto anticorrupción. - He ordenado con
un decreto legislativo que las empresas
condenadas por corrupción nunca más
puedan contratar con el estado. He dispiuesto
la muerte civil de los funcionarios
corruptos para que nunca más puedan
trabajar en el estado. A partir de hoy
todos los contratos de concesión del
estado peruano obligatoriamente
incorporarán las cláusulas anti
corrupción con la finalidad de
resguardar nuestros intereses como país".
Ojo que estamos hablando aquí de una
ley más dura incluso que la de
Dinamarca.
Esta muerte civil de la que hablamos
significa que cualquier empresa
condenada por corrupción no tiene ni
siquiera la oportunidad de hacer ese
proceso que decíamos antes de
autolimpieza. Es decir, que a partir de
ahora cualquiera que quiera sobornar a
alguien en Perú se lo tendrá que
pensar dos veces.
Además, el gobierno ofrece recompensas a
cualquier ciudadano que denuncie un
caso de corrupción y ha sacado un
código ético que deberán seguir todos
los funcionarios de la administración
peruana.
Por supuesto que todo esto sólo es el
principio,
ninguna ley anticorrupción está
completa sin los mecanismos efectivos de
transparencia.
Es decir que cualquier ciudadano pueda
acceder de forma sencilla a todos los
documentos del gobierno y que pueda
conocer por ejemplo lo que ganan los
políticos antes y después de haber
ocupado sin función pública.
En este sentido internet permite la
publicación de grandes bases de datos a
la que puede acceder cualquiera sin
necesidad de pedir ningún permiso a un
funcionario. Y al gobierno de Perú.
todavía tienen un largo camino que
recorrer en este campo pero al menos
hasta ahora tenemos que reconocer que
Pedro Pablo Kuczynski ha sido el único
presidente latinoamericano que ha
respondido al escándalo de Odebrecht con
medidas reales. Es decir que en
VisualPolitik de la misma forma que
criticamos a los políticos cuando hacen
las cosas mal,
también tenemos que reconocer cuando
hacen las cosas bien y de hecho no es la
primera vez que aplaudimos este hombre.
En este otro vídeo explicamos por qué
Pedro Pablo Kucynski es uno de los tres
líderes políticos del año 2016.
Si queréis verlo podéis hacer clic
aquí. - "A pesar de todo, tal como
vimos en un pasado vídeo, el país lo está haciendo muy bien en los últimos años.
Está creciendo, la pobreza disminuye y parece
que poco a poco
finalmente las instituciones se están
asentando.
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿creéis que los
países latinos incluyendo españa y
portugal
tenemos que cambiar nuestras leyes para
acabar de una vez por todas con la
corrupción?
¿Creéis que odebrecht puede ser una
oportunidad para que los países
latinoamericanos por fin pongan medidas
y limpien sus gobiernos? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
y esperad porque todavía tengo una cosa
muy importante que decir.
Este mes de marzo voy a estar en España
dando tres conferencias. Me han invitado
a participar en un evento que se llama
el Free Market Agregar a diccionario y concretamente voy
a estar hablando en sevilla santiago de
compostela y gijón.
Si alguno de vosotros quiere acercarse a
una de estas charlas encontraréis más
información en los enlaces de la
descripción.
Y también encontrareis los documentos
escritos por la profesora teresa medina
de la universidad de burgos que es una
de las mayores expertas en lucha contra
la corrupción y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vividos nuevos
todas la semanas, así que suscribiros
al canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
un abrazo y hasta pronto